All right. Sophie Alcorn,
thank you for being on my show
20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Hi Michael. I'm doing great.
It is really awesome to be here.
Thank you so much.
Well, thank you for giving me
your generous time
even in the late evening.
I really appreciate it.
Sophie, who are you?
Where are you even calling from right now?
I am calling you
from Mountain View, California.
I live in Silicon Valley,
San Francisco Bay Area,
so very close to Stanford.
And I am an immigration attorney.
I'm a top 10 California
immigration lawyer, certified specialist
by the state bar and my law firm,
Alcorn Immigration Law,
focuses on startup immigration.
So, it's great to be here.
Wonderful.
Okay, so there's much to talk about.
Before we get to startup immigration,
what is immigration law in its essence?
And obviously, this is something that
immigration, ever since
the past decade I think,
has been somewhat of a heated topic
in this country as I'm starting to learn.
Give me a little bit of context as to why
this is such a complicated matter,
and what is immigration law?
I love that question.
That's such a brilliant,
I love starting with the philosophical.
Immigration is people want to move.
We're on this globe, and the land
doesn't come with walls, but we build them
and then we want to get past them.
And so, immigration law
is helping people navigate
those walls and borders.
And it's an especially interesting time
to think about it
not just because
of all the political things
that are happening and covid, but also
augmented reality, virtual reality,
future of work, like what is
immigration going to be in the future.
So immigration, as the world
is becoming more globalized,
as a young entrepreneur,
I'm imagining that there should be
a pretty linear correlation:
the more globalized the world is,
the easier it will be for people
to move between countries.
Now, of course, I'm imagining
you're specializing in the US,
but is this the case?
Or, because it doesn't seem so from the news
that it's becoming easier
as the world gets more globalized.
Well, certainly in the United States
it's becoming harder.
And other countries,
over the last couple decades,
have also been on a path towards
increased restrictionism and xenophobia,
which might be a backlash
to globalization.
For people in the know
it may be easier than ever,
but it's not obvious in every situation.
Right.
So, what is the context of immigration law
within the sphere of Silicon Valley?
Is it the same as just
regular immigration law or not?
No, it's different and it's wonderful,
I think, it's so fun.
I love the brilliant minds that come here
from all over the world
drawn by places like Stanford,
Berkeley, Google, Apple.
People are so excited to come here
and start companies
and meet venture capitalists,
and so I'm thrilled because I get to talk
to brilliant people every day
who are working on such
diverse pursuits and topics.
So, immigration law is different here
than in the rest of the country,
and I practiced
in different areas geographically.
And in some of my
prior legal incarnations,
it was more about
supporting undocumented people
or victims of domestic violence
or children who had been separated
from their families, human trafficking.
There's lots of really intense things
that go on with respect to immigration
that are very important.
And legally speaking, as a practitioner,
it's very challenging because the law
is stacked against people
in these situations often,
and it can definitely lead to burnout
and compassion fatigue,
which I experienced.
...
Okay, great. So in prior times
in my law career,
I did a lot of really intense cases
that led me to have compassion fatigue
that were super meaningful
and also extremely challenging.
So like asylum, domestic violence,
human trafficking, deportation.
And so, I welcome the opportunity
that I have now
to work with really bright people,
to learn from my clients as entrepreneurs
who think about disruption
and system change.
And yes, I can do some of that
pro bono work right now,
but I'm also looking at ways
to create more systemic change and reform
and to bring what we can model here out
to the rest of the country and
potentially the world.
Sure. So, take me back a little bit
because it doesn't seem
like this is just something
somebody stumbles onto and says,
"Oh okay, I'm gonna be
an immigration attorney
and I'm gonna found my own firm"
a very, very successful firm
in Silicon Valley of all places.
So, give me your background.
How do you even get
sucked into this world?
So, my dad was an immigration lawyer.
My mom is an immigrant from Germany.
She was his client.
And so, I grew up
in an immigrant household
with a dad who was, in the '80s,
loving being like David versus Goliath
and doing all these
crazy deportation battles
and being in the courtroom.
He was a former Marine,
and he loved the adrenaline of that.
And he had his own immigration law firm
in Southern California.
And so I grew up, we would have people
over for dinner and it was normal
to have Ukrainian nuclear physicists
and Vietnamese businessmen
and artists and singers.
So, my parents definitely cultivated
that appreciation for just getting
to know people from all over the world.
And I worked for my dad,
and from compassion fatigue kind of
burned out after a couple years,
and that's the time in my life
when I had my kids.
And through, my marriage ended up
back in Silicon Valley
where my ex and I had met at Stanford.
And so, we came back here for his job,
and I was a stay at home mom
for several years.
Didn't have a professional network
in the Bay Area, just maybe
a handful of friends from college
who I was still a little bit connected with.
But my, it was a lot. It is a crazy story.
Basically, my dad
passed away unexpectedly.
I had argued with him about disinherit, like
I wanted to disinherit myself
not knowing that he was going to die,
but then he did.
And I didn't know
he was gonna disinherit me
but he did.
And then, I got to the point
of my prior marriage where
it also wasn't going to work anymore.
So, I was a mom to a toddler and preschooler
who didn't have a career
and was trying to figure out a way
to pay rent in Silicon Valley.
And I really wanted to be an entrepreneur
and I thought about
going to coding school,
but it seemed like that would maybe
not be the quickest way
to get into the ecosystem.
Wow.
So, I started the firm out of my kitchen,
and it's grown really fast
over the last four and a half,
five years since I started it.
So, you start the firm
out of your kitchen.
You say,
"I could go to a coding school,
but I'll just start a law firm."
Give me a little bit of taste as to what
Alcorn Immigration Law is today.
What is this group?
How many cases do you see?
It is one of the
most well known firms in the country
for immigration law,
but what's happening now with it?
Well, we've bootstrapped.
We have about a team
of 15 attorneys and paralegals.
We have a distributed team
across the country
which we've had for a while,
so that was great
to have in place pre-covid.
We kind of went digital.
And we have helped thousands
of international individuals
from all over the world
get visas and green cards
to live and work legally in the States.
We focus on entrepreneurs and investors,
inventors, researchers, engineers.
And from the law firm base,
I've started a podcast,
"Immigration Law for Tech Startups"
I'm a TechCrunch contributor
with a weekly immigration
advice column, Dear Sophie.
And it's really fun.
Things are happening really fast.
Tell me a little bit about this column.
So TechCrunch column,
Dear Sophie. How does it work?
So, basically people write in
their immigration questions,
and then every week
I answer somebody's questions
with an in-depth legal educational article
about the technical details
of immigration law,
and it's within the Extra Crunch brand
that TechCrunch has.
What is the most complicated part
of immigration law?
So, what are some things
that, obviously the whole thing
to somebody who's not a lawyer is like
a black box that I have no idea
how anything over there works.
But what are some of the deep complexity
that you have to deal with
on a daily basis to help people
get access to this country?
Well, the stories are so moving.
I mean, just within the last 24 hours,
the people I've spoken with,
like a startup founder
who won a bunch of awards
got stuck in Canada,
got denied her visa,
and is now trying to figure out a way
to come back in,
and somebody really wants to hire her.
Do they start a company in Canada
just so she can work there for a year?
Wow. Really?
Yeah.
And then another startup founder
who's trying to break away
from his company,
and he needs to lay the plan to do it
without jeopardizing his current job.
But his co-founder needs to be secure.
But they're trying to get a contract
and they don't want to violate
their offer letter or any non-disclosure
of confidential information stuff.
So, how do they start the company
without working there
and without violating that?
And then, so that was just the morning.
And then somebody with a friend
who's trying to have
the wife and kid live here,
but they don't have a way to stay.
Then somebody stuck in India
working at a big tech company
who the government is really scrutinizing
whether she's extraordinary or not.
Wow.
And then, somebody else who just found out
from a big company
that their visas got denied,
but this means that,
since their last status expired
like four months ago,
that they have to basically
leave immediately.
They don't know if their company
is gonna bring them back in,
if the company cares enough,
so how do they find a way to stay.
That was just today.
I didn't even like roll back
for the last 24 hours.
Wow.
That's unbelievable.
So, I mean, is this also
the best part of the job?
Getting to hear everybody's stories
and getting exposed to.
Because these are like big life decisions, right?
Like where am I going to be based and live.
This is not just, you know,
this is serious stuff.
It's really serious stuff.
The best thing is winning.
The best thing is taking
the impossible situation
and transforming it,
and somebody getting
their sense of freedom
for the first time in their life.
What is the success ratio
of something like this?
Well, take the H-1B visa, for example,
which is a very common working visa
for professionals.
Under Obama and prior administrations
it was approved about 93% of the time
and maybe 5% of the time
there was something called
a request for evidence.
Under the current administration,
the last statistic
I saw the approval rate declined.
It was at 93%,
now it was hovering at 70%.
Really?
And the requests for evidence had gone up
from 5% to 30%.
So, it's gotten very intense,
but we are still winning those.
I cannot guarantee
any future outcome ethically,
but historically speaking,
looking at past data, we have been winning
H-1Bs like 97% of the time.
Wow.
Okay. That's incredible.
And so, is the engagement with the client,
is the lifetime or it just that
that one act of getting that visa?
Or is it something that's ongoing
and you need to have continuous support
and engagement with them?
Well, so we're focusing
on the startup ecosystem.
So, we start with the founder
who's often an immigrant,
get their immigration situation figured out,
and then stick with them
through the raises, the growth,
and basically to bring on
whole engineering teams
often in deep tech.
And for any one individual,
it's like a visa, a green card,
and then citizenship,
but they might have
several different types of visas
before they ever get a green card.
Right. And so, when
there are different firms
that are helping startups grow,
a lot of the times they'll take,
let's say, equity,
and join the company's venture
...
and it doesn't sound like
this is something that could be fitting perhaps
to this model.
Does it happen?
Or is this all engagements with people
but you're just knowledgeable
about the company that they're starting?
Well, because you asked,
I have not historically
been able to do that,
but I'm actually trying to recruit
an MBA intern volunteer,
ideally from a place like Stanford,
who can help write the business plan
for the immigrant focused accelerator
that I want to form
that we have VC interest for.
And with that structure in place,
we would then be able to do
like immigration for equity sort of thing.
Wow. Okay.
That's very, very cool.
Give me a little bit of higher context
as to where we're headed.
And I mean, immigration,
it's such a complicated concept
on its own, but where is this
whole ecosystem headed?
And what needs to change
for things to get better
if they do need to get better?
A lot of places in the world have realized
because they have not been
as economically privileged
as the United States has been
in recent decades,
that immigration is actually great
for the economy, for creating jobs,
and for increasing the quality of life
of their citizens.
So, in the next 5, 10 years,
I think the US is at a critical point,
and I want to help usher us forward
into appreciating the value
and contributions of immigrants.
And I think that that could be a real key
to getting out of the economic situation
that we currently find ourselves in
'cause immigrants create jobs.
... to be an immigrant.
Right.
So, it sounds like it's really contentious
in a place like the United States
because of nationalism
and some arguments about the economy.
At the end, you're seeing it very
from a humane perspective of-
Well, I mean, whatever your motivation is.
Like if you just want to talk about money,
immigrants have money.
Like if you want to talk
about human rights,
it's the right thing to do.
If you want to talk about kindness
and loving your neighbor
and that if we help one person
it helps us all,
we can have it that way, too.
So, it's a win win.
So, five years ago,
starting out in your kitchen,
now, you're running a 15 person law firm
that's recognized as one of the top
for immigration law.
What's next? Where are you headed?
So many things.
I need to hop off this call
in a couple minutes
because I'm having my first
diplomatic Zoom meeting
with a minister of a country
to talk about their innovation economy
and supporting women and children
through innovation.
Wow. Amazing
So, it's really exciting.
The accelerator is on there.
I founded a nonprofit called
The Community for Global Innovation.
We're looking for tech companies
to take the pledge that they are
open to hiring international graduates
and won't hold that against them.
- Wonderful
The sky's the limit.
I love it. I love it.
Okay. So, I have to release you
to go talk to the minister of innovation.
But before that,
I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself
and why those three words.
Okay.
Driven, I think you know why.
Adventurous, because I love having
new adventures and trying new things.
And silly,
because I'm actually really quite silly.
I love it.
Sophie, thank you so, so much
for your time and for the inspiration.
And best of luck winning every case
and helping every person
fulfill their personal dream
whether it's personal or professional.
Thank you very much. Take care.
Thank you so much. Bye.
Bye bye.
Wonderful.